[Música]
a maior parte de vocês
chegou até aqui de carro e você sequer
precisaram pensar pra colocar o cinto de
segurança
isso porque é um hábito mas há 21 anos
não era um hábito ao cinto de segurança
a maior parte de vocês também deve se
lembrar que a gente andava por aí sem
cinto de segurança e no caso dos
motociclistas também sem capacete foi
apenas 97 com o atual código de trânsito
brasileiro que isso realmente começou a
tornar um hábito
eu achava que a gente não ia mudar esse
hábito na época mas felizmente a gente
mudou
hoje todo mundo e concorda que essa
intenção realmente necessários apenas
sete anos se você entrasse num
restaurante num bar ou no teatro a
chance de ter alguém fumando lá dentro
era bem grande
se ted fosse realizado apenas alguns
anos talvez alguém acendeu um cigarro e
do seu lado agora mais trágico do que
isso era o fumo em aviões e foi proibido
no brasil só em 98
são apenas duas décadas aí a gente podia
fumar durante o vôo no brasil na época
em 98 quando foi proibido
muita gente reclamou também dizer que
não é invasão de privacidade e que a
pessoa deveria ter o direito de escolher
onde quer fumar
hoje felizmente o hábito é não fazer
isso ea nossa história traz também
passagens que com certeza nós
gostaríamos que nunca tivessem existido
no brasil em 1888 a maior parte da
população era a favor por exemplo de
compra e venda de pessoas hoje
concordamos que isso é uma atitude
absolutamente inaceitável
não é ético não é moral mas na época em
que a lei áurea foi promulgada
muita gente reclamou principalmente
fazendeiros e latifundiários que diziam
que seria um desastre para a economia
afinal café cana de açúcar e outras
riquezas do brasil eram produzidos
basicamente com mão de obra escrava
hoje a gente realmente enxerga isso como
algo que não deveria ter acontecido
a gente enxerga isso como algo
moralmente inaceitável
eu acredito que no futuro as pessoas vão
olhar para o consumo de animais e vão
entender que aquilo era algo que
realmente não deveria ter acontecido ou
se em algum momento foi necessário que
tivesse o seu fim muito mais rápido do
que o que a gente tem passado agora
atualmente a minha história começa em
eu nasci em vinhedo aqui bem perto onde
está agora sou filho de nordestinos e
crescer em um sítio
eu experimentei coisa na minha infância
que eu tenho certeza que a maioria de
vocês não experimentou e provavelmente
não gostaria de experimentar patas e
estômago de boi eram rotina na minha
casa toda semana tinha na minha casa
também tinha bife ovos e laticínios
esses eu tenho certeza que também tinha
na casa de vocês mas o que não tinha na
minha casa e eu acredito que também não
tinha na casa de vocês é uma conversa a
respeito do hábito de consumir mais
eu vi a minha mãe matando animais no
quintal de casa eu via de longe e achava
aquilo algo realmente violento mas todas
as pessoas que eu conhecia inclusive os
meus próprios pais diziam que eu
precisava consumir mais que eu precisava
comer carne para crescer forte e eu
cresci com aquela idéia então é algo
realmente é um mau porque algo violento
e bastante desagradável mas é necessário
porque me diziam que era pra alimentação
então cresci com isso a companhia mais é
um mal necessário
chama atenção aí pra inscrição que tinha
na minha blusa na foto de dois anos
a fazenda não aquela do canal de
televisão obviamente mas sim uma
fazendinha de animais
eu tinha essa blusa não por coincidência
porque todas as crianças têm uma grande
empatia pelos animais
prova disso é que quase todos os
personagens infantis são representações
de animais é pig mickey mouse pernalonga
pato donald
quase todos que vocês conseguirem e se
lembrar
vão ser representações de animais agora
convido vocês a pensarem um pouco atrás
voltar um pouco no tempo quando vocês
eram crianças como vocês reagiriam se
quem matasse um animal na frente de
vocês alguém pegasse uma faca cortar sua
garganta desse animal cortasse em
pedaços e colocasse no supermercado para
vender
se vocês pudessem fazer alguma coisa com
certeza vocês fariam nem que fosse
chorar e ficar desesperados com isso mas
com o tempo a gente vai crescendo e um
mundo vai nos dizendo que existem
animais para respeitar para ter como
membros da família prado em casa e
outros animais para comer para
simplesmente não ligar pra eles
então passamos de crianças protetoras e
amantes de todos os animais para adultos
consumidores vorazes de suas carnes e
secreções
mas como uma mudança tão drástica e tão
violenta acontece embaixo do nosso nariz
com a gente mesmo ea gente nem pensa
nisso não comenta não conversa sobre
isso
além da questão cultural que passa de
pai para filho a publicidade tem uma
grande influência na morte de milhões de
animais no mundo
a publicidade faz você não enxergar aqui
na indústria do leite por exemplo as
vacas são mortas logo após deixarem de
dar o número de litros de leite que o
fazendeiro que é
todas elas são mortas nessa mesma
indústria os animais que nascem machos
ou são motos logo após o nascimento
descartados para a graxaria ou são
criados em condições bem questionáveis
para seu modo para serem mortos depois
de alguns meses e vir a carne de vitela
à mesma publicidade usa ícones da nossa
infância personagens que gostamos muito
pra vender pra gente animais mortos
na hora que a gente acorda até a hora
que a gente vai dormir muitas vezes
esses personagens são representações de
animais vendendo outros animais e às
vezes a gente não pensa nisso
quem é que tem um cachorrinho um gatinho
em casa
vocês vão concordar comigo especialmente
aqui na nossa civilização na nossa
sociedade ocidental
os cães e gatos são tidos como membros
da família lembra do seu bichinho na sua
casa
comer carne de cachorro ou tomar leite
de cadela
são atitudes absolutamente repulsivas
soou estranho
no entanto consumir leite de vaca ou de
algumas outras poucas espécies e comer
carne de boi
hoje algumas outras poucas espécies
também a gente deixa passar
parece algo moralmente aceitável o que
eu quero de vocês hoje é que vocês têm e
expandir o círculo de compaixão de vocês
e que vocês dêem a todas as espécies de
animais o mesmo respeito que vocês acham
que cães e gatos devem ter por muito
tempo eu olhava imagens como essa e não
chegava a minha parcela de culpa nisso
eu vi que parecia algo errado que os
animais estavam ali naqueles caminhões
sendo transportados para cima e para
baixo com medo machucados amontoados
baixo de sol forte e muitas vezes mas eu
não vi não achava que era comigo aquilo
eu via aqueles peixes no supermercado
sabem cima do gelo todos modos e passava
o meu carrinho às vezes até pegar um
peixe pra levar pra voltar pra casa e eu
não pensava a respeito disso não era
culpa minha entendeu não pensava a
respeito disso houve aqueles caminhões
aqui no interior de são paulo quem é
daqui vai concordar comigo que existem
muitos caminhões aqui de aves passando
pra cima pra baixo e eu vi aquele monte
de animais ali sou forte machucados
assustados e eu não me dava conta de que
na verdade era eu que tinha colocado
aquele animal dentro do caminhão com a
minha demanda por produtos de origem
animal
eu convido vocês agora a trocar de lugar
por alguns segundos com esse boi está
prestes a ser assassinado
eu gostaria que você imaginar sem a
sensação de impotência que até as pernas
amarradas está num ambiente
completamente desconhecido ea única
coisa que você consegue enxergar é que
alguém vem se aproximando com uma faca
para justamente portar sua garganta
em 2012 o neurocientista canadense
philip lowe redigir um documento
extremamente importante que a gente tem
hoje chamado declaração de cambridge
esse documento foi apresentado no
importante evento científico e foi
assinado por 27 grandes cientistas esse
documento resumidamente diz o seguinte
que os animais têm consciência de que
eles realmente podem sentir a maioria
dos sentimentos que a gente sente e
sofre
acontece alguma coisa ruim com ele isso
é signatário desse documento e presente
no evento de lançamento estava ninguém
menos que esteve em alguém que nos
deixou há poucos dias infelizmente pra
mim
a ficha realmente começou a cair em 2006
eu comecei a pesquisar no youtube a
respeito de abate de animais eu trazia
quilo da infância a mal necessário e aí
comecei a pesquisar sobre isso já depois
de adulto e cada vez que eu pesquisava
eu percebi que eu precisava pesquisar
muito mais e aí uma saudosa rede social
que vocês já devem ter reconhecido pelas
cores orkut alguém dizer o seguinte você
não precisa comer animais
aquilo mexeu profundamente comigo porque
apesar da simplicidade da frase eu tinha
que ir na cabeça é um mal necessário de
repente alguém falou que era
desnecessário então ficou apenas mal com
apenas ruim
aí eu comecei a pesquisar mas será que
realmente desnecessário não é possível
enganar a vida inteira então em pouco
tempo de pesquisa e descobriu que para
nossa saúde realmente a gente não
precisa de absolutamente nada de origem
animal
a posição oficial do crn3 que o conselho
regional de nutricionistas mais
relevante aqui no país inclusive e do
próprio ministério da saúde é que você
não precisa de nada animal em uma fase
da sua vida
mais do que isso a posição oficial da
organização mundial da saúde oms que é
um braço da onu é que as carnes
vermelhas provavelmente causam câncer
elas estão no grupo 2 de risco de câncer
da oms
no grupo 1 estão as carnes processadas
elas efetivamente causam câncer existem
evidências para afirmar que esse tipo de
produto hoje em dia
causa câncer e as caras que estão nesse
grupo um risco de câncer da oms são
bacon presunto salame e todos os
embutidos que vocês podem imaginar
para vocês terem idéia da seriedade
dessa informação e foi divulgado em 2015
no grupo 1 de risco de câncer da oms
estão o tabaco ea fumaça do óleo diesel
se você não se importa tanto com a sua
saúde não tá nem aí pro jetos animais
não entendo respeito mas com o meio
ambiente é bem provável que você deva
importar porque em algum momento isso
vai voltar pra você ou para seus filhos
alguém que você gosta
então aqui vai um dado 14 6 por cento de
todas as emissões de gases do efeito
estufa causadas pelo ser humano vem da
pecuária
o brasil tem o maior rebanho bovino
comercial do mundo tem 218 milhões
depois aqui no nosso país enquanto temos
apenas 208 milhões de pessoas
sim nós temos 10 milhões a mais
depois aqui no brasil e para alimentar
tanto bom a gente queria o quê
monoculturas soja milho sorgo e outros
grãos são criados para complementar a
alimentação desses animais e também para
serem exportados para alimentar animais
que são criados em regime intensivo ou
seja em gaiolas ou galpões lá na ásia ou
na europa e com a água
vocês se preocupam com água diminuir o
tempo do banho já fecham a torneira na
hora de escovar os dentes muito bem isso
deve ser incentivado
mas existe uma coisa que você deve fazer
é que vai poupar muito mais água no seu
dia a dia que é escolher o que você
coloca no prato
isso porque cada produto cada alimento
tem um nível de litros de água que usa
para ser produzido e os produtos de
origem animal estão lá em cima na lista
dos que mais gastam para vocês terem uma
idéia a água gasta na produção de um
bife de apenas 100 gramas equivale a um
chuveiro aberto por três horas e tem
gente que consome duas vezes por dia mas
será que com tanta informação que estou
recebendo agora só que vale a pena mesmo
navegando uma mas acho que não vai fazer
diferença
vamos continuar destruindo o meio
ambiente e os animais vão ser mortos
mesmo jeito
bom eu sempre usa esse exemplo você não
pode resolver sozinho lixo do mundo né
sozinho não vai resolver mas não vai
jogar uma garrafa pet da janela de seu
carro
ou seja faça assim a sua parte porque
faz diferença e cada vez que você faz a
sua parte
você inspira mais pessoas a fazerem
também tá então vou ter que viver de
salada e se descarta também propõe
felizmente não tem também as saladas mas
para tudo o que vocês gostam hoje que
vocês comem existe uma versão sem nada
de origem animal existe uma versão
e gana eu comi todos esses pratos sair e
muitos outros e muitas vezes eu posso
garantir que as versões veganas são tão
boas quanto ou até melhores do que as
versões dos pratos originais então
sabendo que é desnecessário e que pode
ser muito gostoso se você pesquisar a
respeito e abrir somente para novos
sabores
acho que tem um convite bem forte para
vocês agora eu gostaria que vocês não
fechassem os olhos para um pequeno vídeo
que eu mesmo editei e cuidar para que
não tivesse imagens muito fortes e que
fossem impossíveis de assistir 662 mil
tocar por semana desta semana foi de 988
mil ha
é que nem fazem a seleção mas depois de
assinar eu achei que não tinha no meio
do mar
assegurado a gente é feito hoje
a barbárie rio em tendo portugal
o rugir
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mas mais interessantes nos últimos
minutos dele é incrível amigo dele ficar
entre escuta mugindo mesmo editar
confinado
é muito apertado fim gente
mal pra mim aquela parte mais densa
[Música]
apesar da nossa constituição federal ao
estabelecer uma proteção ampla animais
vedando a prioridade apesar de a lei dos
crimes ambientais o tempo todo que
ficava um crime de maus tratos e abuso e
não consegui entender que é normal esse
tipo de procedimento que se faz um
matador
[Música]
o brasil mata legalmente um boi e um
porco e 191 frangos são 193 animais por
segundo
no curto período de tempo em que você
esteve assistindo a essa apresentação
duzentos e oito mil quatrocentos e
quarenta animais foram mortos legalmente
pela pecuária brasileira por conta da
demanda de produtos de origem animal
você tem pelo menos três chances por dia
de fazer escolhas que sejam boas para os
animais
uma no café da manhã uma no almoço e
outra no jantar
por favor façam escolhas que não
envolvam vítimas
você pode fazer parte do grupo de
pessoas que está mudando esse hábito de
consumir animais
considerem um organismo muito obrigado
[Aplausos]